good afternoon we're glad to see such a
turnout for this event that is to
highlight how we're using digital
technology at Yale to meet our goals in
teaching this is one of several Center
for teaching and learning forums and so
we're glad to see you at this one and
hope that you will come to others
fundamentally teachers are
experimentalists we try something if it
works we keep doing it if it doesn't
work we scrap that and try something
else we're very much scientific I hope
at least in terms of how we take on
ideas about what works in teaching but
at the same time teachers are also
thieves in the sense that we're very
much about trying to find ideas that
work and we don't necessarily really
care where we find them and so if we
find things that work and we saw them in
work that someone else was doing all the
better for an opportunity to incorporate
them into our own teaching and so
effectively what this form is is it's an
opportunity to do some just wholesale
wholesale thievery as we look to borrow
teaching ideas from each other and
utilize those teaching ideas in
technology the same kind of principles
of looking for ideas in teaching and
incorporating them into our own or as
our own is what we're setting about this
week is we have faculty Bulldog days
which is an opportunity for all of us to
visit each other's classroom and see
what's happening in those classrooms and
the kind of techniques that are being
utilized specifically today we're
looking at the opportunity to use
technology in our teaching to
incorporate ideas of technology whether
it be through the learning management
systems we use or other kind of
technology platforms to be able to
incorporate those into our own teaching
for effective student learning so I look
forward to what we will hear from the
speakers as well as from the panelists
it's my pleasure at this point to
introduce our keynote speaker Dean
Marvin Chen who was recently appointed
to be the new dean of Yale College he is
the Richard M Colgate professor of
psychology and
professor of Neurobiology his background
is that he received his PhD from MIT and
he's taught at both Harvard and
Vanderbilt and he began teaching at Yale
in 1996 one of the things that Marvin
uses is zoom in a summer session online
course but it's also been my pleasure
over the past few months since he became
dean to see his love for being able to
do assessment and analytics of teaching
to be able to use data to make decisions
about what's happening and what's
working in the classroom and so it's a
pleasure to to see that excitement about
what data can do whether it be through
the canvas learning management system or
broader analytics about what's happening
in the university so it's my pleasure to
welcome Dean Chun and turn the podium
over to you thank you so thank you very
much for having me I'm very grateful for
your participation today and also for
the invitation to join this fabulous
session from the center for teaching and
learning I also like how my kind of
informal opening remarks turned into a
keynote speech poem and so but I'll try
to speak a little more informally I'll
have try to cover two themes in my brief
remarks one is I just want to share why
I teach which which may be a little
redundant for an audience who clearly
has showing strong motivation and
appreciation for good teaching and then
the second topic is what how I
discovered how I feel that interaction
is so important in the classroom and how
digital technology is enhancing our ways
to interact with our students in the
classroom so just just to share a few
things about why I teach and this is
what I you know I think about this all
the time especially in my new dean role
especially as I collaborate with so many
people on campus so many amazing people
I I kind of don't accept the standard
sense that there is a tension or or a
conflict or trade-off between
scholarship and teaching or research and
teaching I find at least I feel that in
my career the two activities have been
incredibly complementary and mutually
reinforcing I especially love teaching
for the same reasons why I love my
particular discipline which is
psychology and neuroscience we like to
we do what we do partly because it's
personally reinforcing but also because
we feel it's it has impact that it's
rewarding to others that what I know if
I share with others will help them do
whatever they want to do better
especially feel that way about
introduction to psychology which I teach
here I think psychology is a very
integral part to a liberal arts
education you know understanding how
people think how people make decisions
how people interact with each other in
what ways can the mind and the brain go
wrong I think these are all things that
I want everyone to think about not just
the specialized researcher as a grad
student postdoc work or professor and so
it's with that motivation I I teach
introduction to psychology at the which
fortunately at Yale is a fairly large
course so I can reach out to a large
number of students and I teach that
again not because I have to fulfill my
teaching obligations to the University
but I really treat it as an opportunity
a privilege to have access to you know
future amazing well currently amazing
students will continue to do amazing
things for the world in all their
different disciplines I go in with that
conviction I literally every time I
stand up there I I can easily imagine
that there's you know my future senator
who's going to determine funding is
sitting there or a future president or a
future NGO work or a future teacher
future Nobel laureate future CEO I just
see that and in the audience and I think
especially we're lucky here at Yale that
that you know that kind of imagination
is actually true that our students do
leave Yale and go on to do amazing
things so if you can plant tiny
seeds from your discipline from your
field that will shape their mind and
help them do better things for the world
I just think that's just an incredible
opportunity and it's why I feel that
teaching is you know a huge privilege
and something that we should try to you
know hone and as craft a skill that we
should try to improve as much as
possible so that so that's just a few
comments on why I think why you're all
here and why I'm here I teach
introduction to psychology
sometimes the class is about 500
students and and we know here at Yale
that students are especially our
students don't like one-directional
lectures they like to interact with each
other they like to interact with the
professor
where possible when possible and so in
at least in my class the digital
technology has has played a very helpful
role in making my classes more
interactive you know at the very basic
you know almost almost banal II basic I
use a lot of videos I use a lot of
interactive demonstrations based on
videos based on computer programs based
on animation I do things where I
literally pose questions to the class I
get them to talk with each other using
these illustrations using these demos
and especially videos I think without
that as you can tell I'm not a very good
speaker but I think my classes have been
well-received because I use these media
in effective ways I don't do like long
five-minute 10 minute videos I most of
my videos will last 30 seconds to a
minute but I do it an interactive way so
I can get the students talking even in a
500 person class the other tool that has
been really really essential for my
introduction to psychology class are the
clickers I've been using clickers for
over 10 years since they first appeared
on campus because this way we can really
do kind of live input from the students
in both a way that's interactive that's
that's
live but thirdly that's anonymous so
that we can collect data do surveys ask
questions from students without them
feeling self-conscious or embarrassed or
intimidated by the size of the class
especially the anonymity of the clickers
has proven really critical and I'll give
you an example of oh you know how of a
demonstration I give in my class that
students find to be very moving and
something that I would not absolutely
would not have been able to do without
the clickers this is covering Traverse
parental investment theory how many of
you some of you I'm sure know prayer
Traverse parental investment theory this
is this is the notion of evolutionary
notion that shows differences between in
all species not just humans but it shows
differences in the way that males and
females approach sexual interactions
there the idea is basically the the sex
which which will differ across species
the sexes that invest more in the in the
birth and and caregiving of an offspring
will be more choosy in a relationship in
choosing a partner and so in the case of
humans because women you know the
pregnancy lasts nine months and because
the bulk of the child-rearing at least
traditionally rests with a mother but
especially the pregnancy it clearly
rests with the mother the idea is that
because that is so expensive
biologically women will be more choosy
than men are when it comes to choosing
partners and so I can describe this in
the way I just did and everyone I just
kind of glazes over or I can do a
questionnaire to test a prediction that
this theory makes which is with your
clickers you can pretend you have
clickers they don't have to answer how
long would you need to know someone
before you be willing to sleep with that
person okay and I can give various
options with the clicker so you one hour
one day one week one month two months
right and so students have the options
they can choose with their clicker
and and then furthermore the technology
allows me to divide up the group
according to men or students who
identify as male and students identify
as female okay so I can answer this I
can ask this question I can't ask them
to raise their hands all right so
clearly that would be boring just
describing the phenomena is boring but
if I do this survey I can analyze a data
online and throw up on the screen and
moreover I can say this isn't data from
some study published 10 years ago it's
not some data collected at some other
population you know in some city very
different from Yale and New Haven this
is literally your data that I'm showing
up live on the screen
and and of course the results are that
God women will take about a week to a
month before they on average before they
feel comfortable sleeping with someone
whereas men in this audience will say
that you know within an hour and a day
they're ready to you know spend the
night with somebody and students get to
see this live and we get to show you
know the predictions of true you know
the parental investment theory but
moreover it allows us to go into even
more meaningful and deep conversations
about these differences and why and you
know how they may relate to and how they
should inform you know the kind of
interactions that healthy interactions
we want students to have with each other
so that's just another example have
digital technology enables a class to be
very interactive very live and and maybe
able to you know touch upon sensitive
topics the other things that are that
that we've explored and that I hope to
continue to explore are things like
canvas Piazza which are message forms
you know as you know this is a social
media generation students like to chat
with each other a ton this is more
relevant for seminars that I taught but
you know one of the most reinforcing and
rewarding things I got from seminars
that i've taught is that students like
that chat with each other about the
class material outside of the classroom
even then when they're not in the same
room and so in the case of when i taught
before canvas piazza was available
which is a kind of a message form a tool
is that they were using groupies they
were using kind of text to each other
just to kind of share papers with each
other or continue to debate things from
the classroom I mean that's how hungry
and motivated our students are but I
think now with tools with like canvas
Piazza and others you know if you could
think of ways in your classroom to
stimulate dialogue and and discussion
outside of the classroom that would be
absolutely phenomenal
so those are just some things I've used
for my large courses to help create
interactivity
I've also during summer teaching I was
fortunate to collaborate with CTL and
its predecessor especially rich Collins
to develop a flipped class where you
know I wanted to continue to teach
introduction to psychology in the summer
but like I'm sure many of you I'd like
to travel in the summer I'd like to be
in Europe I'd like to be in Korea in
Asia and and so it's hard to teach for
five weeks straight during the summer
and and so I offered my introduction to
psychology class as a flipped class we
taped all the lectures student would
watch all the lectures offline and then
we would meet for a regular time twice a
week on this program called zoom which
is which is like a a group Skype or a
group FaceTime for you know that can
hold up to like 15 to 20 people at a
time on the screen but but it's just
infinitely infinitely better than
anything you've probably ever used Skype
face time or any other media source can
zoom is spectacular has anyone used it
before okay
preaching to the choir and zoom has been
really amazing because it's just
technically smoothness but it what I
love the most about it is that it makes
the class flat in the sense that there's
no depth to the room if you're in a
seminar room you have people who are
close to you you have people way in the
back you have people some people in the
you know in the kind of the seats hiding
away but in zoom you really can't hide
and everyone has to engage and
classroom because it's a flat-screen and
on top of that your little your name
comes up on the bottom and so it's
really easy to call out on people I just
think it's a fabulous technology that
really enables the flipped classroom to
work well you know and so I think with
these technologies I would love for
people to think about distance learning
where students can you know learn
languages that are not offered it you
know personally I'm very excited about
vln u.s. College and Singapore and the
possible pedagogical opportunities that
exist by collaborating with faculty and
students there there are 12 hours away
and it would be wonderful if we could do
something that is more collaborative
with them during the term I never I
don't think you know we ever want to
replace you know have zoom replace live
interactions in sections I definitely
don't I'm not proposing that I really
think that live interaction in the
classroom is is really what's special
about Yale and especially our
residential college system so I don't
think a flipped I don't want to use zoom
to replace live interaction on campus
but if it's with colleagues students
with learning opportunities from a
distance I think we should consider
these powerful tools just to more online
examples that I think are very exciting
one is online experiences for Yale
scholars with a code name of OU Nexus
this is helping a cohort of incoming
Yale students to prepare for the rigors
of quantitative study at Yale math and
especially in the domain of math so it's
essentially a bridge program we have an
outstanding bridge program called
first-year scholars at Yale which helps
students who come from under-resourced
high schools or a little bit less
preparation because of their
socioeconomic backgrounds to help them
transition smoothly to Yale by giving
them a little bit of a some
bootstrapping and some some essential
skills over a summer program
it's absolutely effective and
outstanding but it's it's it's cost
prohibitive to extend to a larger a much
larger group of students and so if we
can think of more online way
to engage with students before they
arrive or even during the summers while
they're here I think these are things
that we should continue to try to pursue
and innovate finally I'll just share you
know this potential possibility of
partnering with Google to and it's very
much in a discussion stages right now
but if there's a way that we can help
teach students coding over the summer
especially to increase the number of
women coders that would be something
that may be difficult to do during the
school term but something that we can do
over the summer especially in an online
format that allows students to go out to
wherever they want to go out and do and
help them you know learn coding offline
or online I should say well while
they're all over the world so these are
just a few examples again I'm just very
passionate about teaching and hence I'm
passionate about this partnership
between the Yale College dean's office
and the Center for teaching and learning
and and I'm really excited about ways to
use digital technology to enhance our
teaching because we would like for you
all to be at the forefront of
technologies and and especially the
quality of teaching that we provide to
our undergraduates this group is much
larger and I'm so happy to see it's so
numerous here today and so thank you
again for coming for your attention and
I hope you have a terrific session I
apologize that I will have to leave at
some point in the afternoon because I
have to go teach so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]